hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today i
have a lot of thoughts on the concept of
change spare change
unspare change character change costume
change so let's get into it with you
me and you p episode 120 started out as
a mystery with the case of the missing
shoot
ended up not being a mystery or in fact
about the missing shoot arguably though
because we didn't get a good look at who
managed to pick shoot up and place him
in the care of those
knuckle really should have been placing
him in the care of instead of going
after a creature he wasn't equipped to
deal with
because he didn't do that and because we
didn't get that
we don't really know for sure whether
whether
crap what's his name bush coward yeah
him his hair turned white but all
shoot saw was a back so we don't know if
it was actually him meanwhile the guy
who should have done something to help
him
a guy who doesn't even really like him
at all which he realized
as his death move but seems to enjoy
getting enraged with him as an excuse to
take out revenge for his own hurt pride
yeah that guy knuckle he still has a lot
to learn about being a good combatant
and
in fact just about being a thoughtful
person in general moving on
everything or most things were through
villainous chibi be
chibi eyes so we could do that thing
where we get an overview of the
battlefield from someone who
really doesn't care about anything
that's happening we even got an overview
of characters we haven't seen for a
while and my
petty bezel-floating self-desperately
wanted hiro to drop that piece of
concrete on him i hate him so much
it seems unreasonable but i look at it
this way the other characters have some
redeeming quality that stops me short of
loathing but he's just a
so hatred seems fair and i have thus
saved my own sense of morality today
it was weird and i'm not sure what
triggered the memory but about two
minutes before hiro and her antler
and butler showed up i started to wonder
where she's at or where she was at she's
back hi
i'm sure there was a visual cue of some
kind i'm not naturally actually a fae
creature
allegedly but her appearance was very
nicely timed shia's villainous chibis
feel like they have so much casual
potential that whenever we get these new
nan abilities i
often wonder why we haven't seen them
before
why didn't poof just send his little
hymns to check on the towns
he could have done that while the king
played games with komugi instead of
reading books and his mini keys
seemed to travel really pretty fast
segue of the year but a villain shire is
a great thing to see
after his monologue explaining all his
plans and how he has
won somehow and i'd love to see a
spin-off of him and wolfboy
trying to take over the world by
functionally doing nothing at all
nothing
speaking of taking over the world back
to gon and pito who are staring each
other down
shire finally has his chance to deal
with the object of his abject hatred and
finish her for good if he plays his
cards right i do wonder whether gon will
fight shire so he doesn't
interfere with the deal they made or if
pito will do the same so
that he doesn't interfere with the deal
they made i sort of hope so to be honest
there's a part of me hoping shia never
makes it to the king
largely because he hates kamugi so much
that he has to do something about that
i also hope morel doesn't die as a
result of knuckles knuckleheadedness but
i guess we'll find out let's move on to
episode
the next episode 121 and we just have to
stop and appreciate
growth standing ovation to the growth of
our favorite calmly raging
non-human fae entity you be whoa yes
yes yes you pink yeah it's my boy
yes up has seen so much growth in the
space of just like i don't know 15
minutes
maybe more but definitely less than an
hour there's so much to be said for the
incredible changes that have taken place
largely physically but especially
emotionally for a character to go from a
very simple killing machine to a very
complex killing machine in an hour is a
rare event
just look at the last however many
episodes it's been since they started
this fight and the number of times i've
said that characters are actively making
the choice not to develop or not
actively making the choice not to
develop but not developing on the whole
it seems that humans are just grossly
inefficient
and unwilling to change and i feel like
i shouldn't be so surprised by that
frankly i'd be happy to bow down before
our sata
centaur mythical greek rage filled calm
deepman
overlords if they could keep developing
like this he's better than the real
world ancient greek pantheon too really
because he's managed thus far to avoid
sexually assaulting anyone in
goose form give it up for yupi
consensually the use of language in this
episode
suggested that yupi's power would be
bankrupted but that presumed knuckle
growing there were a few situations
where the narrator here misled
us and that's the largest one that i
noticed it makes me wonder who is
actually narrating and it's something
i've considered before
especially since some of the narration
i've mentioned as being odd the idea
that the narrator's on everyone's side
the idea that he knows what's going on
in everyone's mind while also
deliberately misinforming us they all
suggest that it might actually be a
character we're not seeing or a
character who watched everything and
spoke to the survivors at the end the
unreliable narrator
is quite an enjoyable character to
observe what has been painful to observe
has been knuckle knuckle has shown on
multiple occasions that he is incapable
of
change his inability to develop while
youp gained my respect is one of the big
surprises for me of this
r despite all the chances knuckle didn't
learn
despite everything that's happened i
don't think any of his group of people
really can if extreme circumstances
can't change someone or make them
reflect
even on their behavior it's hard to see
how smaller ones could
someone once said that some people only
change when they lose enough people keep
saving knuckle from the experience of
actual loss up denying him the chance to
fight isn't real loss he got
saved from it by others and from yupi
saying hey go get him medical attention
because he's respectful the fact that he
reverted to not being able to fight yupi
isn't him
learning to quell his pride but a growth
of his pride and a reflection
on morales i think it was morale
actually uh yeah his but
aren't they here to stop the ants taking
over the world while i love the morality
and ethical questions involved i find it
quite frustrating that what's taking
them out of a fight is the fact that
they didn't consider their enemies might
have similar beliefs or values to them
it just feels like basic reconnaissance
to me that i think
now gives me context for the stupidity
of war so i guess you know
thanks to gaushi essentially the only
way knuckle would fight the ants or this
one
particularly was if he was in an out
group or seen as
other morel knows better morel knows
that despite everything else there is a
goal
morel is uh what we would call maybe a
good soldier he's willing to give his
life to the cause for the cause and put
aside his pride knuckle ain't that if
they make it out of this alive
and it's a huge if i hope morel sends
knuckle away because he'll just keep
endangering people
possibly worse knuckles fatal flaw is
that he humanized up
or rather up showed he wasn't just a
creature to be exterminated and it
resulted in knuckle being unable to
fight him which is
such a ridiculously manipulatable flaw
that i don't understand
why he and shoot were considered among
the best choices for this job given
there are so many other
hunters or there are supposed to be the
last thing i want now is for him to go
tripping on other characters toes and
it's just a slow waiting game until he
manages to get someone killed really
isn't it if knuckle wins it's because he
managed to trip over
himself and you know or like he crouches
down to do his shoelaces and someone
falls off him and goes over a cliff like
it's not it's not like he's going to
save the day and if he does i'm going to
be so mad
knuckle has just bumbled into every
situation and actively made poor choices
every step of the way it's not even that
i specifically want the humans to win or
the ants to win i'm really not sure
what i do know is that incompetence
really annoys me
especially when you're supposed to be a
specialist at your job and you're
failing because of your own incredibly
changeable flaws
imagine if he just ignored his pride
once
just once and maybe that's what's
annoying me it's not even that there's a
fight going on between the ants and the
humans it's a fight between the humans
and the humans because while
you pee developing dribbling skills and
hardcore moves like dual emotions
one of which is his arm he has a rage
arm now knuckle
is scoring own goals i'm baffled i guess
by the idea that this guy was sent in to
save the world when he can't even save
himself a whole world and they chose the
hyper-empathetic
hyper-selfish impulsive knucklehead okay
anyway
having thrown enough shade at knuckle
for him to freeze in an australian
summer it was sort of
nice and heartbreaking to see nov again
aging
at the speed of light he definitely was
the one who rescued shoot and i don't
know what else to say about him except
that he must have been allergic to those
bushes or something
maybe we could try antihistamines i pity
him
especially since his all-seeing
apprentice is in a cocoon waiting to
hatch or
like i don't know wrapped up like like
frodo in
in that movie with the with the the
rings and the lord
finally the gone pito shia la perth
triad is taking my interest
only one of the three wants kamuki dead
cheyenne knows pito lied to him god
knows pito will do what he wants because
i don't know that
gone could have been aware when violin
butterfree came in what we do know
is that pito is playing a dangerous game
and i'm kind of excited to see what
comes of it all that's hopefully what's
coming next episode as well as it
finally being time to check in on what
happened with natero and marouane
because it's been mentioned now
that means we have to come to it we have
to come back to it we have to talk about
it i'm ready whatever the fight was that
they had it's likely over now and we're
just waiting to see if the king returns
because if i'm honest i don't think no
terror stood a chance beyond the pretty
time-based light show they put on
sorry natero i'm excited to see what
happens next but for now
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
tree i grew directly to loom shade over
knuckle who's a nice guy but really an
awful combatant
click here here and here don't forget to
like share and subscribe
and i'll see you next time